Y con cada año que pasa,
esta no observación, esta falta de evidencia
de cualquier actividad alienígena, se vuelve más desconcertante
porque deberíamos verlos, ¿no es así?
El universo tiene 13,8 mil millones de años,
más o menos.
Si representamos la edad del universo como un año,
nuestra especie apareció aproximadamente 12 minutos antes de la medianoche,
del 31 de diciembre.
La civilización occidental ha existido por unos segundos.
Las civilizaciones extraterrestres podrían haber comenzado en meses de verano.
Imaginen una civilización de verano
que ha desarrollado un nivel de tecnología más avanzado que el nuestro,
pero de tecnología basada en la física aceptada,
no estoy hablando de agujeros de gusano o unidades warp, --lo que sea--,
solo una extrapolación del tipo de tecnología que TED celebra.
Esa civilización podría programar sondas autorreplicantes
para visitar cada sistema planetario en la galaxia.
Si lanzaron las primeras sondas justo tras la medianoche de un día de agosto,
entonces, antes del desayuno el mismo día,
podrían haber colonizado la galaxia.
La colonización intergaláctica no es mucho más difícil,
solo lleva más tiempo.
Una civilización de cualquiera de los millones de galaxias
podría haber colonizado nuestra galaxia.
¿Parece exagerado?
Tal vez lo sea,
pero ¿los extraterrestres no harían alguna actividad reconocible...
poner mundos alrededor de una estrella para capturar la luz solar libre,
colaborar en Wikipedia Galáctica,
o simplemente gritarle al universo: "Estamos aquí"?
Entonces, ¿dónde están todos?
Es un acertijo porque esperamos que estas civilizaciones existan, ¿no es así?
Después de todo, podría haber un billón de planetas en la galaxia...
quizás más.
No necesitas ningún conocimiento especial para considerar esta pregunta,
y lo he explorado con mucha gente a lo largo de los años.
Y he descubierto que a menudo enmarcan su pensamiento
en términos de las barreras que tendrían que ser despejadas
si un planeta debe albergar una civilización comunicativa.
Y generalmente identifican cuatro barreras clave.
Habitabilidad...
esa es la primera barrera.
Necesitamos un planeta terrestre en justo esta "zona de habitabilidad"
donde el agua fluye como un líquido.
Están por ahí.
En 2016 los astrónomos confirmaron que hay un planeta en la zona habitable
de la estrella más cercana,
Próxima Centauri...
tan cerca que el proyecto Breakthrough Starshot planea enviar sondas allí.
Nos convertiríamos en una especie que visita estrellas.
Pero no todos los mundos son habitables.
Algunos estarán demasiado cerca de una estrella y se freirán,
algunos demasiado lejos y se congelarán.
Abiogénesis...
la creación de vida desde la no vida...
esa es la segunda barrera.
Los elementos básicos de la vida no son exclusivos de la Tierra:
los aminoácidos se han encontrado en los cometas,
moléculas orgánicas complejas en nubes de polvo interestelar,
agua en sistemas exoplanetarios.
Los ingredientes están ahí,
solo que no sabemos cómo se combinan para crear vida,
y, presumiblemente, habrá mundos en los que la vida no comenzará.
El desarrollo de la civilización tecnológica es una tercera barrera.
Algunos dicen que ya compartimos nuestro planeta con inteligencias alienígenas.
Un estudio de 2011 mostró que los elefantes
pueden cooperar para resolver problemas.
Un estudio de 2010 mostró
que un pulpo en cautividad puede reconocer a diferentes humanos.
Los estudios de 2017 muestran que los cuervos pueden planificar eventos futuros:
criaturas maravillosas e inteligentes...
pero no pueden contemplar el proyecto Breakthrough Starshot,
y si desaparecemos hoy,
no implementarían Breakthrough Starshot...
¿Por qué deberían hacerlo?
La evolución no tiene viajes espaciales como objetivo final.
Habrá mundos donde la vida no da lugar a una tecnología avanzada.
Comunicación a través del espacio: esa es una cuarta barrera.
Tal vez las civilizaciones avanzadas eligen explorar el espacio interior
en lugar del espacio exterior,
o ingeniería a distancias pequeñas en lugar de grandes.
O tal vez simplemente no quieren arriesgarse a un encuentro
con un vecino potencialmente más avanzado y hostil.
Habrá mundos donde, por la razón que sea,
las civilizaciones o guardan silencio
o no pasan mucho tiempo tratando de comunicarse.
En cuanto a la altura de las barreras,
su conjetura es tan buena como la de cualquiera.
En mi experiencia,
cuando las personas se sientan y hacen las matemáticas,
por lo general, concluyen que hay miles de civilizaciones en la galaxia.
Pero luego volvemos al rompecabezas: ¿dónde está todo el mundo?
Por definición,
ovnis, incluido el que vi,
están sin identificar.
No podemos simplemente inferir que son naves espaciales.
Todavía uno puede divertirse con la idea de que los alienígenas existen.
Algunos dicen que una civilización de verano colonizó la galaxia
y sembró la Tierra con vida...
otros, que estamos viviendo en una reserva cósmica de desierto
un zoológico.
Aun otros...
que estamos viviendo en una simulación.
Los programadores simplemente aún no han revelado a los alienígenas.
La mayoría de mis colegas, sin embargo, argumentan que ET está por ahí,
solo tenemos que seguir buscando,
y esto tiene sentido.
El espacio es vasto.
Identificar una señal es difícil
y no hemos estado buscando tanto tiempo.
Sin duda, deberíamos gastar más en la búsqueda.
Se trata de entender nuestro lugar en el universo.
Es una pregunta demasiado importante como para ignorarla.
Pero hay una respuesta obvia:
estamos solos.
Somos solo nosotros.
Podría haber un billón de planetas en la galaxia.
¿Es plausible que seamos las únicas criaturas capaces de hacer esta pregunta?
Bueno, sí, porque en este contexto,
no sabemos si un billón es un gran número.
En 2000 Peter Ward y Don Brownlee propusieron la idea de la Tierra Rara.
¿Recuerdan esas cuatro barreras
que la gente usa para estimar el número de civilizaciones?
Ward y Brownlee dijeron que podría haber más.
Veamos una posible barrera.
Es una sugerencia reciente de David Waltham,
un geofísico.
Esta es mi versión muy simplificada
del argumento mucho más sofisticado de Dave.
Podemos estar aquí ahora
porque los habitantes anteriores de la Tierra disfrutaron
4 mil millones de años de buen tiempo...
altibajos, pero más o menos clemente.
Pero la estabilidad climática a largo plazo es extraña,
si solo porque las influencias astronómicas
puede empujar a un planeta hacia la congelación o a freírse.
Hay una pista de que nuestra Luna ha ayudado,
y eso es interesante
porque la teoría predominante es
que la Luna surgió cuando Theia,
un cuerpo del tamaño de Marte,
se estrelló con una Tierra recién formada.
El resultado de ese choque pudo haber sido un sistema Tierra-Luna bastante diferente.
Terminamos con una gran Luna
y eso permitió que la Tierra tuviera una inclinación axial estable
y una velocidad de rotación lenta.
Ambos factores influyen en el clima
y la sugerencia es que han ayudado a moderar el cambio climático.
Genial para nosotros, ¿verdad?
Pero Waltham demostró que si la Luna fuera
solo unos pocos kilómetros más grande,
las cosas serían diferentes.
El eje de rotación de la Tierra ahora vagaría caóticamente.
Habrá episodios de rápido cambio climático...
no es bueno para la vida compleja.
La Luna tiene el tamaño correcto:
grande pero no demasiado grande.
Una Luna de "habitabilidad" alrededor de un planeta "habitable"...
una barrera tal vez.
Pueden imaginar más barreras.
Por ejemplo,
las células simples surgieron hace miles de millones de años...
pero tal vez el desarrollo de la vida compleja
necesitaba una serie de eventos improbables.
Una vez que la vida en la Tierra tuvo acceso a la multicelularidad
y estructuras genéticas sofisticadas,
y sexo,
nuevas oportunidades se abrieron:
los animales se hicieron posibles.
Pero tal vez es el destino de muchos planetas
que la vida se establezca a nivel de células simples.
Puramente a efectos de ilustración,
déjenme sugerir cuatro barreras más para agregar a los cuatro
que la gente dijo que bloquean el camino a la civilización comunicativa.
De nuevo, puramente con fines de ilustración,
supongamos que hay una probabilidad de uno en mil de cruzar cada barrera.
Por supuesto, podría haber diferentes formas de superarlas,
y algunas oportunidades serán mejores que una en mil.
Igualmente, podría haber más barreras
y algunas posibilidades pueden ser una en un millón.
Veamos qué pasa en esta imagen.
Si la galaxia contiene un billón de planetas,
¿cuántos alojarán una civilización capaz de contemplar como nosotros
proyectos como Breakthrough Starshot?
Habitabilidad...
el tipo correcto de planeta alrededor del tipo correcto de estrella...
el billón se convierte en mil millones.
Estabilidad...
un clima que permanece benigno por eones...
los mil millones se convierten en un millón.
La vida debe comenzar
el millón se convierte en mil.
Deben surgir formas de vida complejas
el mil se convierte en uno.
Se debe desarrollar un uso sofisticado de herramientas...
ese es un planeta en mil galaxias.
Para entender el universo,
tendrán que desarrollar las técnicas de ciencia y matemáticas.
ese es un planeta en un millón de galaxias.
Para llegar a las estrellas, tendrán que ser criaturas sociales,
capaces de discutir conceptos abstractos entre sí
usando gramática compleja...
un planeta en mil millones de galaxias.
Y deben evitar el desastre...
no solo autoinfligido, sino también desde el cielo.
Ese planeta alrededor de Próxima Centauri,
el año pasado fue destruido por una llamarada.
Un planeta en billones de galaxias,
al igual que en el universo visible.
Creo que estamos solos.
Esos colegas míos que están de acuerdo en que estamos solos
a menudo ven una barrera por delante
bioterror,
calentamiento global, guerra.
Un universo que es silencioso
porque la tecnología misma forma la barrera
para el desarrollo de una civilización verdaderamente avanzada.
Deprimente, ¿verdad?
Estoy argumentando exactamente lo contrario.
Crecí viendo "Star Trek" y "Forbidden Planet"
y vi un ovni una vez,
entonces esta idea de soledad cósmica
ciertamente me resulta un poco melancólica.
Pero para mí,
el silencio del universo está gritando,
"Somos las criaturas que tuvimos suerte".
Todas las barreras están detrás nuestro.
Somos la única especie que las ha superado...
la única especie capaz de determinar su propio destino.
Y si aprendemos a apreciar cuán especial es nuestro planeta,
qué tan importante es cuidar nuestra casa
y para encontrar a otros,
cuán increíblemente afortunados somos todos
simplemente al estar conscientes del universo,
la humanidad podría sobrevivir por un tiempo.
Y todas esas cosas increíbles
que soñamos que los extraterrestres podrían haber hecho en el pasado,
ese podría ser nuestro futuro
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)